we're going to focus on derivatives
today we will get to integration but we
don't have really the time today or the
mental or emotional space so we'll just
focus on the derivatives and the
integrals will come afterwards
this is y equals sign it's everything we
need to know about the trigonometric
functions will start with sine X and we
will expand from there so that's why you
can see I've drawn it and what we're
going to do before I just show you
results we want to use that intuition
someone really smart taught me once upon
a time if you've got a problem you
should always try guessing first just
try again see what your gut tells you
because go away if you guess and you're
right you'll be like I'm freaking
awesome
and if you're not right you'll be like
hmm now what was wrong with my intuition
and you'll learn something so that's
that's pretty good right yeah not that
kind of I said if you had a question
like this right
not like what will happen if I jump off
this cliff okay that's not the kind of
intuition I'm referring to
so here's y equals sine X and what I
want us to do is think about the
gradient function of this graph because
that's all the derivative is trying to
find right now a lot of this we don't
know about but there are some particular
points on this graph where you can not
just roughly you can exactly tell me
what the gradient will be at those
points have a look I count on the part
that I've drawn I count one two three
four spots exactly where you should be
able to tell me what the precise grading
is can you see them
okay now we'll come to the origin
shortly but actually unless you've done
this before
if you're coming to this just like I am
right now in like I don't know what the
derivative of this thing is then you do
know you do not know what the gradient
is here but if you look at four other
points namely this one this one this one
and this one you should know exactly
what the gradient is at those points
what's it going to be equal to it should
be zero because what kinds of points are
those they are stationary points right
local max local min etc so at those
points on this same graph I'm going to
put that's a zero there for the gradient
that's what my other color is going to
be here's another spot where the
gradient is zero and so on okay now I'm
gonna go one step further I just did a
very rough graph I didn't put any values
on there but you actually know those
values right because we've been dealing
with the sine curve for a while now we
know what its amplitude is but in
radians and I'm gonna come back to why
it's radians in a minute in radians I
wonder if you know those spots well
enough to know their values what some
this first
stationary point what's its value its x
value it should be PI on two right 90
degrees because if you think about it
here's nought to 360 yeah well sorry
there's 360 that's a quarter the way
there so that's nine degrees that's PI
on to you let's let's write that in PI
on - okay your next one over
what's that stationary point
that should be 3 pi on 2 right because
look it's 1 2 3 of them
so you're right 3 p.m. to these ones out
here not in the normal domain in which I
draw but I think we can work them out
right because for example this next one
is there's 3.2 I go another pilot 2 and
another player onto so it should be 5 PI
on to and what about this one back here
we don't usually draw this part yeah
it's just you can see the symmetry of it
can't you so I'm going to put negative
PI on two over there ok so far so good
so I know a bunch of spots where the
gradient is zero but I can go more than
that right
do you notice in between those
stationary points some parts of sine are
increasing and some parts are decreasing
so when a function is increasing what
does that tell you about its greater
it's going to be positive is gonna be
above the x-axis right so where's a spot
that you can see where you have an
increasing function there's a whole
bunch pick one between zero to plant two
that's increasing I think you could make
it even bigger than that country like I
can see that this section here is also
increasing do you get that from here all
the way up to here it's increasing okay
so with this color which is my gradient
color I'm going to show up here the
gradient should be positive okay by the
same logic but in Reverse
having looked between PI on 2 & 3 PI on
to what you told me about the gradient
there it's decreasing
[Music]
okay and then predictably you get it
reversing and coming back up here now
this is interesting right
the gradient seems to be doing the same
thing over and over again it hits zero a
whole bunch of times repeatedly and
there's no reason why I wouldn't
continue doing that and also seems to be
doing this up and down and up and down
right in other words it's periodic the
gradient seems to be repeating over
periods of time why would the gradient
be periodic because the function I'm
thinking about right now
the sine curve it's periodic so
therefore it stands to reason its
gradient ought to be now think about
this for a second the gradient function
is a periodic function it goes up and
down and up and down and it goes through
these particular x-intercepts
Payan 23.2 etc finally I knew a function
that was periodic and went up and down
up and down and had these particular
values that it passes through does
anyone know one that does have a look
starts up here and it goes down and then
it comes up that sounds a whole lot like
cosine right and just have a think about
this if you were to draw a cosine in
here right it would look something like
this
we're about to yeah
[Music]
there's cause X right now we've filled
in a whole lot more but it goes through
all of the zeros all of those intercepts
it goes through all of those regions
that I painted and it even tells you a
little bit more for instance we looked
at stationary points but the sine curve
also has points of inflection can you
see where they are have a look at those
points of inflection where are they
I use a different color I can see a
point to reflection say here do you see
the inflection can you cover up my bar
you a book all right if you cover up
this spot here looking at that blue
curve right that's sign do you see that
concave down clearly there's the concave
down section and then if I go on the
other side there it is that's clearly
concave
you see the change in concavity yeah
that's a point of inflection Thank You
Arian you've got a whole bunch of other
ones like there's one there's one have a
look at what cosine does at those points
of inflection do you see that it's got a
Station Airport is this ringing bells
from when we gave you questions like
here's a graph told me the derivative
right and then tell me the dream of that
it's exactly what we ought to expect so
our intuition tells us this
but intuition is not enough in
mathematics we need to press a little
further in